beginning in march dc comics will change
superman's traditional red and blue
costume
to a new form-fitting bodysuit the
problem with the old costume
not gay enough
i need heaven resort i need
all-inclusive when i die that's what i
need
so all the resort religions you gotta
hate gay people that's part of the
religion
for some reason and it's like i can't
hate you if i haven't tried it
man like i don't think i like dick but
it's a hunch you know
it's i'm not certain
it's a hypothesis i'm really not willing
to test you know
i had a friend who was like i know i
don't like dick i was like you
know you know like that
what you mean you know you tasted it
what's the flavor what's the flavor of
dick
is it cilantro because then i don't like
that [ __ ] neither cause that would clear
up a lot of [ __ ]
we act like gay sex is so [ __ ] crazy
so foreign right
is it really that form i like girl but
probably not that different from dude
but maybe a few less hairs in it
hopefully
i'll take it one step further i like
touching my dick
ain't a man in this room that could look
me in the eyes and say they don't enjoy
touching dick
matter of fact you've been enjoying
touching dick longer you've been
touching [ __ ] that's a fact
i'm gonna go and judge the next man just
because he's less selfish than you
[ __ ] you and
now it's time for weekend updates movie
reviews
this week i saw interview with the
vampire
and here's here's my review um
not gay enough
[Applause]
i got a lot of fears man i got a lot of
fears as a parent
let me tell you guys one of my biggest
fears one of my biggest fears is my son
growing up
and being gay that's a fear keep in mind
i'm not homophobic i have nothing
against gay people be happy
do what you want to do but me being a
heterosexual male if i can prevent my
son from being gay i will
now with that being said i don't know if
i handle my son's first gay moment
correctly like every kid has a gay
moment okay every kid but when it
happens you gotta nip it in the bud you
gotta stop it right then
hey stop that's good it's quick
no i don't know
i don't know if i handle my son's
situation right okay he's at a birthday
party right
my son had a birthday party he's playing
you know when kids play
they just play you don't know what
they're doing but they're having a good
time they're just doing a bunch of stuff
right they're moving around i said okay
he's good i finished talking i turned
back around to check on my son again
a little boy was grinding on my son ass
he was like this i didn't know what to
do i panicked i knocked them both down
hey what's going on here what kind of
party is this
huh what kind of party is this what's
going on here
this lady came out she's like what are
you doing they kids let them play
i said will you show me another kid
getting [ __ ] an ass and i'll calm down
my son had on corduroy's that's why i
had an attitude
because i didn't see it i heard it all i
heard was
who the hell is playing cards what is
that
is somebody shuffling cards they're too
young for spades here
the thing to piss me off here's a pissed
me off man
i was eating a buffalo wing when it
happened i should have dropped the wing
and ran over there but i lit my fingers
first
i didn't mean it i said hey boy
in overseas news an attempt to lift the
ban on gays serving in the british armed
forces
has been defeated in parliament this
raises a difficult legal question
how do you exactly tell if a british guy
is gay
[Applause]
i never understood people uh uh judging
people for the way they have sex so some
people get angry at homosexuals just for
being gay they get mad at them
i never really understood that you know
like because they're just having sex
with each other it's like like i can
understand if gay people were just
running out in the streets just [ __ ]
people they asked willy nilly just like
a pestilence
like without asking you know like you're
at the atm hey what the [ __ ]
jesus god damn it some [ __ ] just
[ __ ] me right in the ass seriously
[ __ ] right through my pants he
[ __ ] ruined my new pants
looking [ __ ] another one goddammit i
gotta get the [ __ ] home this is
ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Music]
but they generally don't do that so i
don't know what the [ __ ] problem is
people get mad they don't want to get
don't get married well you don't have to
go to the wedding with the [ __ ] you
don't have to buy him anything
it doesn't matter some people go like
well then a guy will marry his dog
good [ __ ] i hope he blows his dog who
gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter
it doesn't have any effect on your life
what the [ __ ] do you care
or people that try to think it'll talk
like it's a social issue
like when you see someone stand up on a
talk show and say like
how am i supposed to explain to my child
that two men are getting married i don't
know it's your shitty kid you [ __ ]
tell them why is that
anyone else's problem two guys are in
love but they can't get married because
you don't want to talk to your ugly
child for [ __ ] five minutes
[ __ ] cares about your shitty kid he's
probably a [ __ ] anyway
how stupid is that all right
that's stupid i don't know
the only the only um thing that bums me
out though is that you're not you're not
supposed to laugh
at gay people when they're funny because
sometimes they just are they're funny
like i lived in new york for a lot of my
life and in my neighborhood everybody
was gay and and it you know some guys
are just a guy walking down the street
but some gay guys are a guy in little
shorts and a half shirt and
you know combat boots spray painted
green and the
whistle and he's standing on the corner
hello [ __ ] hot outside
that's not a stereotype those guys
[ __ ] exist by the thousands
and when i see them i laugh really loud
i just do
and be like don't laugh at him because
he's getting no i'm not laughing because
he's [ __ ] weird and silly
he's hilarious
[Applause]
how am i supposed to react hello oh
hello
hello yes seriousness
yes
it's stupid
the only actually the one guy i would
blow uh
based on based on who he is
is ewan mcgregor that there is this one
guy out there i gotta say
that i have no gay inclinations except
for i
met this [ __ ] dude in person i was
working on some awards show and there
he's standing right there and i was like
[ __ ] like i was just blown away like
jesus
christ he's [ __ ] beautiful
and he looked at me and he was like
hello and i was like i [ __ ] shivered
like i started shivering
like [ __ ] [ __ ] gorgeous
and like a week later i just i was like
staring off into space somewhere and i
realized [ __ ] i was just daydreaming
about
you and mcgregor
like seriously i'm not gay in any other
way except for i want to [ __ ] that guy
right in the face i
totally want to [ __ ] his face i want to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of his face i want him
to [ __ ] me i do i want him to [ __ ] me
well it's the last show here we are
in los angeles the world capital of
rape and dick brown
the [ __ ] has been going on out here
it keeps getting worse but just what you
think can't get worse they got charlie
rose today
it's gonna be a quiet morning on the
news tomorrow
charlie rose who's next captain kangaroo
every is raping like hot cakes
i for one i'm starting to get worried
you know i've been in show business 30
years i had no idea how much danger i
was in
it's really some scary [ __ ]
i got to tell you harvey weinstein is
probably the first person that i ever
looked at a photograph of and was like
yeah he rapes
not a handsome man not a lot of meat and
extra skin on his face
hey he's ugly you know the sad part is
he's done so well in life
he probably doesn't know he's ugly you
know when you're good looking
everybody will tell you oh you look
wonderful you're so great looking
when we ugly you got to figure that [ __ ]
out for yourself
it's a lot of putting clues together
here it is
why am i not getting in the club i got
all the right [ __ ]
it was brad pitt doing that [ __ ] he
wouldn't hurt a peep
the girl just come back down like i got
the part
[Applause]
and yet and yet it is important that i
acknowledge ladies
you are absolutely right
there you go
they gotta all be mindful of that guys
because uh
it's gonna happen to any of us it could
happen to me
i can see that by 3 a.m with mr
weinstein
hey harvey i got your text i'm here to
talk about the script
seems like it's gonna be hard to read
and candlelight but i guess i could try
it sound like a [ __ ] nightmare could
you imagine that [ __ ]
did you imagine using a business meeting
and a [ __ ]
pulled their dick out
in the middle of the meet i be like yo
yo my man it's the most unprofessional
[ __ ] i've ever seen
in all my days
just let me finish dave chappelle
i'll put you in all three lord of the
rings
hurry up [ __ ] i have other meetings you
know
i have a 4 30 a.m in brett ratner's
house
i believe it's wardrobe fitting